good acting often requires years of
training a ton of effort and a little
luck sometimes though no amount of any
of those things can help otherwise
talented actors affect an accent that's
simply beyond their abilities these are
the on-screen accents that were
absolutely horrendous
just because you once starred in an
austin powers movie doesn't mean you can
actually pull off a decent british
accent just ask heather graham
perhaps the worst part of graham's
atrocious accent in the 2001 ripper
flick from hell is that she just can't
seem to decide which one to go with the
united kingdom is home to dozens of
different accents and dialects
unfortunately it seems that graham is
unable to pull off any of them well you
better throw us in jail then because we
have no money for food and no money for
a dos
during this movie graham jumps from
cockney to a kind of irish to something
altogether unintelligible proving that
the actress may just have benefited from
some more thorough accent coaching
in fact sometimes it seems like she's
barely even trying at all and simply
sounds more like a hollywood actress
than a white chapel local
i wish i could show you the little
village where i was born
it's so lovely there
not even a spoonful of sugar can make
dick van dyke's attempt at cockney
english more palatable
in fact he himself once called his work
in the 1964 classic mary poppins quote
the most atrocious cockney accent in the
history of cinema what did i tell you
there's the whole world at your feet
at the time however van dyke didn't know
how far off he really was as the actor
later told the guardian someone should
have told me i needed to work on my
cockney accent nearly everyone in the
mary poppins cast was a brit but no one
said anything
years later i asked julie andrews why
didn't you tell me she said it was
because i was working so hard still van
dyke continues to keep a positive
attitude about the whole thing despite
actual brits apparently never letting
him forget it he explained
people in the uk love to rib me about my
accent i will never live it down they
ask what part of england i was meant to
be from and i say it was a little shire
in the north where most of the people
were from ohio
i always say there's nothing like a good
joke
what happens when a french american
actor plays an immortal scottish
swordsman well something like this this
cannot be
it's the devil's work
christopher lambert's fake scottish
accent in 1986's highlander is
undoubtedly one of the worst to ever hit
the big screen
most of the time lambert barely sounds
scottish at all and the movie isn't
helped by the fact that actual scottish
actor sean connery plays an egyptian
spaniard who sounds neither egyptian nor
spanish
he does however sound a lot like sean
connery i am juan sanchez villalobos
ramirez
chief metallurgist to king charles fifth
of spain and i'm at your service
but hey who needs accents when you have
the mccloud mcleod longsword
having cemented his reputation as a
major blockbuster movie star in the
early 90s tom cruise decided to prove
that he could really act so not long
after earning an oscar nomination for
born on the 4th of july he signed up for
far and away co-written and directed by
ron howard and co-starring cruz's wife
nicole kidman far and away tells the
epic story of a young irish immigrant
couple who arrive in the united states
in the late 19th century searching for a
better life but in his efforts to play a
representative of the 1800s irish
diaspora he missed one major element a
decent irish accent i'm not going to a
distant world i'm a violent and i'll
stay in ireland till i die
in 2021 irish central called cruz's
voice work quote truly appalling and
added that it sounds like how a
hollywood film executive imagines irish
people talk
leonardo dicaprio is one of the best
actors of his generation and in 2007 he
earned his third academy award
nomination for blood diamond in expose
of the inhumane brutal and deadly
diamond trade in africa the film takes
place during the sierra leone civil war
in the 1990s dicaprio plays danny archer
a diamond smuggler turned activist who
hails from zimbabwe but spent years in
south africa both of those countries
were colonized and long occupied by
european nations namely the uk and the
netherlands but dicaprio's accent in the
movie doesn't sound much like a typical
south african accent nor does it seem
english or dutch-based either instead
dicaprio's character sounds more like he
might be from another part of the world
entirely a few americans the americans
love to talk about your feelings huh
so what what does that mean what does
that mean
trevor noah a native of south africa
even called out dicaprio's voice
performance on a 2019 episode of the
daily show we gotta go back to those
bloody get the diamonds
get the bloody diamonds what are you a
drunk australian what are you doing
martin scorsese's crime thriller the
departed is an epic tale with a hefty
and confident state of place
that place being boston scorsese loaded
the cast with actors well known for
their beantown roots including mark
wahlberg and matt damon but he also
brought in the legendary jack nicholson
who portrays irish-american gang boss
frank costello
maybe scorsese thought that wahlberg and
damon's natural accents were enough for
this very bostonian movie or that their
speech patterns would simply rub off on
nicholson or maybe he just thought that
nicholson would do his job as one of the
most acclaimed actors of all time and
give that massachusetts brogue a try
alas
the crown
sort of thing
to be fair sometimes nicholson does
provide a serviceable accent dropping an
r here and there like a true native
boston man but then on occasion he'll
give a line reading in a genuinely
comical hugely over-the-top irish
accent that shines in her hair
justin timberlake is an entertainer at
heart his career began in childhood when
he was a member of the always singing
dancing and smiling mickey mouse club
and later found mega fame as a member of
the boy band nsync timberlake brought
that same kind of intense energy to some
of his early film acting roles
particularly that of arrogant french
canadian hockey player jacques grande in
the mike myers 2008 comedy the loveguru
timberlake goes as big broad and wacky
as he possibly could have in the film so
naturally he opts for a truly cartoonish
french accent reminiscent more of pepe
le pew than an actual french speaker
stay away from my girlfriend
the real problem here however is that
jacques isn't french he's french
canadian which is supposed to be a
distinctive dialect in of itself
robin hood is a distinctively english
folk hero a rogue ex-aristocrat in the
english system he steals from the rich
and gives to the poor operating with his
band of merry men out of a home base in
sherwood forest near the city of
nottingham
the tale of robin hood has been put to
film many times including a take in 2010
that cost nearly 200 million dollars
producers likely wanted to make sure
they got a good return on their
investment and preferred a bankable star
in the title role
someone like russell crowe for example
perhaps it just didn't matter then that
crow does not will not and seemingly
cannot speak with an east midlands
accent the regional english dialect used
around nottingham
every englishman's home is his
what we would castle
your majesty
is liberty
upon robin hood's release critics
quickly called out crow's accent the
actor even abruptly left an interview
with a bbc radio host who said he
sounded more irish than english eight
years later actor khan o'neal brought up
crow's robin hood accent on twitter
crowe replied that his accent was
supposed to be that of a child born in
barnsley on his father's death taken to
france at age six travels across europe
to the middle east on foot fights in the
third crusade for richard the first
alongside men from all parts of britain
ireland and france and finally returns
to england a man in his 40s
in the 1997 action movie conair nicholas
cage plays a recently paroled convict
and former u.s army ranger who gets
stuck on a prisoner transport plane
after it's hijacked by the other
prisoners his character cameron poe is
said to be from alabama so cage affects
a slow languid draw and seems to be
aiming for something close to forced
gump by way of foghorn leghorn nice jet
you can take cindino and leave the rest
to rot for all our care
you fire that weapon 20 pissed off
prisoners are going to hear it
this is an especially strange choice for
cage a notoriously quirky man who speaks
with a twinge of the south in real life
even though he was born in burbank
california
sam worthington starred in the highest
grossing film ever released and yet he
probably could still walk down the
street unaccosted because the scenes in
avatar in which his face was actually on
screen were kept to a bare minimum the
australian actor's time as jake sully in
the movie is mostly spent as a
combination of cgi and voice acting as
his character inhabits a lab-grown
avatar meant to look like the inhabitant
of an alien planet unfortunately this
means that the audience is basically
forced to focus on jake's voice
naturally then many have noticed that
worthington's attempt at sounding like a
tough american marine veteran actually
sounds like anything but i needed their
help
[Music]
and they needed mine
but to ever face them again
i was gonna have to take it to a whole
new level
his prominent australian accent leaks
through often during the movie despite
undergoing extensive work with a dialect
coach before filming began but maybe
there's only so much you can work with
after all as director james cameron told
total film his accent was thicker than
crocodile dundee
in a crowded cast of terrific actors at
the top of their game don cheadle
somehow managed to pull off one of the
most memorable performances in the 2001
remake of ocean's 11. he played bashar
tarr the member of danny ocean's heist
crew who is an expert in explosives and
who is supposed to come from a british
working class background cheetah was
born in the american midwest however so
he worked hard with an onset speech
coach in order to perfect his
character's cockney accent although
perfect might not be the right word all
right chips
hang on to your [ __ ]
once the movie was released however it
appears that cheedle's accent provoked a
few strong reactions the actor later
said that on a visit to london someone
would come up and say love that
character mate it's great and the next
street someone would come up and say
don't ever do that again someone did a
u-turn to come drive by me and cuss me
out for the part cheadle is so over the
criticism of his accent in fact that he
has even taken to supporting a fan
theory that explains why it sounds so
off that basher is really an american
pretending to be a cockney brit
oliver stone's natural born killers is
an eye-popping style hopping
extravaganza
the movie follows spree killers mickey
and mallory knox whose criminal fame is
spurred on by wayne gale the host of a
trashy tv show called american maniacs
robert downey jr is both lowsome and
bombastic as the exploitative and
ratings-hungry gale whom stone later
explained is based on a combination of
geraldo rivera and australian tabloid
journalist steve dunleavy
it's actually the latter's australian
accent that downey is trying to imitate
here but he doesn't quite get it right
do you think that those nitwits out
there and zombie men remember anything
instead downey's accent is some bizarre
combination of south african a couple of
different british dialects some new
zealand vocal features and perhaps just
a hint of australian
in 2005 oscar-winning filmmaker cameron
crowe received the worst reviews of his
career with his rom-com flick elizabeth
town starring english actor orlando
bloom it appears that elizabethtown
doesn't really know what kind of movie
it wants to be
it's a romantic comedy but it's also
about a guy mourning his father's death
as well as a professional redemption
story and a movie about a man returning
to his hometown similarly bloom is all
over the place with his accent despite
some extensive accent training at the
time the actor said it wasn't easy to
master an american accent i had a lot of
help from a dialect coach but i did all
right no
a billion dollars
that's a lot of million
bloom's character is supposed to be a
kentucky native but the actor is never
able to really commit to a specific
southern accent the way he delivers the
script's dialogue in a wishy-washy
non-specific american way is a little
reminiscent of that of his co-star alec
baldwin but for some reason it also
sounds kind of scottish too how's that
going sort of a wait and see
oh yeah
but then i waited and i saw
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]